salut à tous vous pensez que les
spartiates étaient des guerriers
barbares vêtu d'un slip en cuir
passablement homosexualiser qui ont leur
nouveau n'est jugée trop faible pour
faire de bons guerriers et bien cette
vidéo est faite pour vous car
aujourd'hui on va parler du
fonctionnement politique de la cité état
de sparte
c'est parti je vous demande de vous
arrêter
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on va donc faire les deux
stars s'étaient de la grèce antique
réputé pour son régime militariste
victime de son image de cité guerrière
souvent caricaturé mais qu'en fait on
connaît souvent assez peu aussi je vous
propose de voir son fonctionnement
politique et sociale de 700 rangée du
cri date de l'instauration de ce régime
militaire jusqu'à 146 avant jésus-christ
date de la conquête romaine
tout d'abord il faut savoir que tout
habitant de sparte et des vides sous sa
domination n'est pas spartiate
aussi quand je voudrais parler des
habitants en général j'emploierai le
terme lassé des magnans un mot qui
rapporte gros scrabble nom venant de là
c'est damon autre nom de sparte et qu'on
utilise souvent pour désigner les
habitants de la région en général la
société lacédémone yen était extrêmement
rare chez eux avec des groupes sociaux
ayant chacun leurs droits et leurs
obligations et le titre spartiates ne
revenait pas à tout habitant du
territoire lassé des manières mais
seulement à une classe précise celle des
citoyens soldats qui formaient alors
d'aristocratie et qui s'identifiaient
entre sous le terme de semblables et non
pas de spartiates comme on les appelle
aujourd'hui être spartiates c'est donc
avant tout appartenir à une classe
sociale précise avant de voir le
fonctionnement politique de la cité état
voyons d'abord quelles sont les
différentes classes sociales et
commençons par les spartiates proprement
dit est semblable
pour être ce parce
maintenant faire part
la dirigeante et guerrière il faut
remplir quatre critères majeurs tout
d'abord être de ligne est spartiate pur
c'est-à-dire avoir un père spartiate et
une mère fille de spartiates
ensuite il faut avoir subi une éducation
particulière la gauche et la cité état
prend très au sérieux d'éducation de ses
futurs citoyens soldats et s'emploie dès
leur plus jeune âge à leur inculquer
l'esprit de corps et de sacrifice qui
font de bons guerriers la collectivité
prend en charge l'éducation des enfants
dès l'âge de 7 ans mais les choses
sérieuses commencent à l'âge de 12 ans à
ce moment là les enfants restant
collectivités dans le temps dortoir et
sont confiés à des éducateurs
tout est fait pour les endurcir il rend
pieds nus une qu'un manteau pour toute
l'année sont mal nourris et encourager à
voler pour compenser et s'ils se font
prendre
on les bat pas parce qu'ils ont roulé et
parce qu'ils se sont fait prendre les
jeunes garçons étaient encourager ce
genre d'acte par toute une série de
concours et de rituels
par exemple un rituel consistait à voler
des fromages disposés sur l'autel
d'artemis des gardiens fouettant le plus
fort possible les jeunes qui tentaient
de les prendre
plus surprenant pour de futurs soldats
l'éducation comprenait aussi un volet
musical avec le chant choral ce type de
chant étant très important à sparte ce
qui était censé développer l'esprit de
groupe
la vie des jeunes étaient également
rythmée par des concours qui avait un
caractère religieux
que ce soit des combats des épreuves
athlétiques ou du chant choral
parmi ces concours on peut citer les
gymnopédies la plus importante fête
lacédémone yens au cours de laquelle
jeunes et adultes participer à des
concours de chant également à
l'adolescence les plus téméraires pouvez
tenter l'épreuve de la crypte où il
s'agissait d'une épreuve consistait à
vivre un an
cachés sur le territoire lacédémoniens
en se débrouillant pour survivre
notamment en volant on suppose qu'il
s'agissait d'une épreuve qui permettait
de former des soldats d'élite notamment
pour les reconnaissances en territoire
ennemi
une fois adultes à 20 ans les jeunes
n'en ont pas fini avec la vie collective
et la troisième condition pro3 spartiate
c'est la participation repas collectifs
quotidien que doivent partager les
citoyens-soldats ses repas collectif
appelé city sont obligatoires de 20 à 60
ans et réunissent des tables et appelé
fratrie de 15 à 20 citoyens
ces fratries côté leurs membres et quand
un jeune rejoignez un groupe qui devait
être acceptée par les autres la
procédure était un peu spéciale car on
procédait alors à un vote a remis un
chacun devant déposer une boulette de
pain
impôts s'ils acceptaient le nouvel
arrivant pour alimenter ses repas chaque
participant devait payer une taxe
mensuelle en nature pour être un bon
spartiate
il faut fournir tous les mois soixante
dix sept litres d'orge 39 litres de vin
trois kilos de fromage et un kilo et
demi de figues alors vous devez vous
dire 39 litres de vin par mois ça fait
plus d'un litre par repas sous son
véritable livre en une ses spartiates et
bien non car en fait une partie de cette
taxe permettrait aussi de payer des
cuisiniers toujours est il que le non
paiement de cette taxe entraîné la perte
du statut de spartiates
alors pour payer en nature lorsque la
possession d'or et d'argent était mal vu
et que les citoyens ne devaient pas
utilisé ces mannes et entre eux ce qui
permettait d'alimenter le mythe de leur
égalité
d'où leur nom de semblable comment
fait-il pour ce pays entre eux s'ils
n'avaient pas le droit d'utiliser leur
ai l'argent eh bien il se payer en
broche
mais attention pas en broche rattacher
les manteaux comme il y en avait à
l'époque non en broche à viande d'un
mètre de long
c'était une ancienne monnaie des changes
en grèce antique la dernière condition
proto spartiates c'est de posséder un
clairon à savoir un lopin de terre qui
est cultivé par les ilotes dont on va
avoir le statut
ensuite et qui permet de fournir
notamment la nourriture pour laisser
city se claireaux c'est une sorte de
fiefs gricole dont les spartiates hérite
de ses parents et qui est non rentables
du moins dans les tensions au delà de
ces condition sinequanone la vie de
spartiates est une ville soldat fait
d'eux des licences aux règles de la
communauté
le service militaire a lieu de 20 à 60
ans il s'agit de la seule activité
professionnelle des citoyens soldats
ceci peut se marier dès l'âge de 20 ans
il ne peut y avoir de vraie vie de
famille qu'à partir de 30 ans âge auquel
ils arrêtent de dormir en dortoir le
mariage n'est d'ailleurs pas un droit
mais plutôt une forme d'obligation
puisqu'il s'agit de donner les futurs
citoyens à la cité ceux qui sont
toujours célibataires passé 30 ans sont
victimes de mesures vexatoires
ils n'en peuvent plus assister au gym de
[ __ ] et doivent faire le tour de
l'agora nul en hiver de quoi les motiver
à se trouver une femme également le
statut de spartiates est un statut qui
se mérite tout au long de la vie puisque
ceux qui ne peuvent plus payer leur part
aussi city qui ont commis des actes de
lâcheté sur le champ de bataille peuvent
être dégradée et devenir des citoyens
sans droits
à côté de cela l'esprit de sacrifice à
la collectivité était valorisé par
exemple seuls les citoyens meurent au
combat avaient droit reinout en valeur
non les autres étant enterrée un âne
la vie des citoyens soldats est une
ville entièrement tourné vers la
collectivité est aussi faite d'émulation
permanente ce qui permet d'affirmer son
individualité la société poussant chacun
être toujours le meilleur
par exemple tous par certains pour
objectif d'être un pays à savoir l'un
des 300 soldats d'élite dont la liste
est revue tous les ans se distingue et
militairement est aussi un faire-valoir
pour ceux qui veulent se présenter
ensuite aux élections alors vous allez
me dire on parle beaucoup des hommes
mais et les femmes dans tout ça comme
partout à cette époque les femmes sont
relégués un rôle subalterne et sont tout
de même plus libre à sparte que dans
nombre d'autres sociétés antiques
il faut dire que la société la cdm agnel
avait une politique eugéniste estimé
qu'une femme forte donnera naissance à
des enfants en bonne santé et donc à de
futurs citoyens selon la swr
aussi les jeunes filles des familles
spartiates été éduqués et avaient des
activités collectives elle pratiquer
l'athlétisme et le chant choral comme
leurs homologues masculins les femmes de
spartiates pouvez aussi posséder des
biens qui on estime qu à certaines
époques
elles ont possédé jusqu'à 40% des ter de
la cité état elle possédait aussi
semble-t-il d'une certaine liberté de
ton et tout cela faisait quelques places
et pour des mégères aux yeux des traits
démocrates à tenir par exemple qui eux
infantiliser leurs femmes
bref maintenant qu'on a vu qu'ils
étaient les spartiates au sens propre
passons aux autres catégories sociales à
vrai dire il n'y a pas grand chose à
dire sur les paires y ait un écran titre
suffira à côté des spartiates qui sont
les seuls citoyens à part entière
le territoire lacédémoniens comporte une
autre catégorie d'hommes libres
l'épée riec qui n'ont pas les
obligations militaires des spartiates
n'ont pas non plus les droits il n'y a
pas grand chose à dire de plus à part
que sont des hommes libres de se
comprend
la troisième catégorie importante de la
cdm indien ce sont les ilotes ce sont
des esclaves public qui ne peuvent être
vendus et dont le statut se rapproche un
peu de celui des serres du moyen-âge non
pas cela voilà c'est celle là
leur rôle est entre autres de cultiver
les terres des citoyens soldats pour
leur fournir de prévision et de quoi
payer leur part au repas collectifs les
relations entre les spartiates et les
ilotes sont extrêmement particulière
les spartiates faisant tout pour
rabaisser symboliquement leurs esclaves
les forces à porter une tenue spécifique
faite en cuir qui marque leurs
conditions inférieures également tous
les ans certains reçoivent des coups de
fouet et rituels au nom de tous même si
bien fait
ils servent aussi d'image négative pour
les jeunes spartiate et par exemple on
les forcer à se saouler pendant les sit
in sans doute pour instruire les jeunes
citoyens soldats sur les méfaits de
l'alcool également les spartiates ont
droit de vie et de mort sur les ilotes
et pour éviter que la mise à mort de
l'un d'entre eux ne soit considéré comme
un meurtre
tous les ans les autorités déclarent
symboliquement la guerre aux esclaves
ce qui fait que juridiquement tué lundi
lot est un acte de guerre ce contraste
entre pilotes et spartiates a souvent
fait dire que les lacédémoniens était à
la fois les plus libres et les plus
serviles des grecs
maintenant qu'on a eu classe sociale à
son fonctionnement politique
déjà il faut
une monarchie une monarchie un peu
spéciale puisqu'elle possède deux rois
ceux ci sont censées avoir une origine
divine puisque selon la légende agissent
te répondent les premiers rois sont les
fils de deux jumeaux euris ténès et
progress qui eux même descendre à des
reculs et donc deux heures quitte à
avoir une origine légendaire autant
choisir une qui a la classe agissez en
répondant une donnée naissance pour
lignée d alger a dit qu'ils disent aux
rayons vides servant avant tout un rôle
militaire et religieux les spartiates
sont très croyants les rois jouent le
rôle d'intermédiaire entre les dieux et
les humains ce sont des grands prêtres
par exemple avant de partir en guerre un
roi fait des sacrifices pour savoir si
les dieux surtout 2 et athéna sont
d'accord pour une campagne militaire il
en fait un appart puis à la frontière du
territoire lacédémoniens et enfin 1
avant le combat
si l'un de ces sacrifices et négatifs
soit on recommence jusqu'à ce qu'il soit
positif soit on recommence à partir en
guerre dans les temps éloignés et de roy
partis ensemble à la guerre mais en 506
avant jésus-christ se produisit ce qu'on
appelle le divorce d'eleusis l'un des
deux rois clio men forment une armée
constituée de spartiate mais aussi de
citer alliés comme corinthe et emmène
tout le monde vers l'objectif que lui
seul connaît
lorsque la troupe s'approche d'athènes
l'armée comprend que l'objectif de la
campagne est remettre au pouvoir
et pias dictateur alors qu'athènes est
en train de devenir une démocratie les
corinthiens ne sont pas très chauds tout
comme le deuxième roi démarrage qui fait
demi tour
les corinthiens voyante les deux rois ne
sont pas d'accord ne s'estime plus lié
par serment et font demi-tour aussi
l'expédition tombe à l'eau et profiter
de ce genre de déconvenue ne se
reproduise après 506 un seul des deux
rois partir en campagne
pendant que l'autre restera sparte si
les rois ont un pouvoir militaire et
religieux le pouvoir politique lui est
dévolue à plusieurs institutions
tout d'abord l'assemblée qui réunit tous
les spartiates d'abord tous les ans puis
toutes les saisons ou tous les mois on
ne sait pas trop de fait cette assemblée
n'est qu'une chambre d'enregistrement
avec un pouvoir limité elle disputer
votre les lois mais ne peut les rédiger
leur rédaction étant le privilège des
deux corps d'élus les efforts et les
gérantes l'assemblée lycées deux types
de magistrats et un mode de scrutin
assez particulier encore plus ristic que
le vote parmi de pain
un jury est enfermé dans un bâtiment
sans qu'ils puissent voir l'assemblée et
ont fait venir un homme les candidats
devant les citoyens ces candidats
déclenché plus ou moins 2020 et celui
qui a été le plus aux passionnés selon
le jury est élu grosso modo c'est une
élection à l'applaudimètre
ce système très rustique de vote à la
criée est aussi utilisé pour voter les
lois
l'assemblée et les donc les efforts ils
sont cinq
élu pour un an et non rééligible
immédiatement ils sont le coeur de
l'appareil politique spartiate et à ce
titre ils ont plusieurs rôles d'abord
ils ont un pouvoir probiotiques
c'est à dire qu'ils préparent les doigts
qui seront proposés au vote de
l'assemblée
ensuite ils ont des pouvoirs judiciaires
il tranche tous les petits conflits liés
aux affaires courantes mais leurs
principales tâches quotidiennes est une
tâche d'administration de police et de
surveillance de la population
d'ailleurs le mot est fort signifie
surveillants par exemple ils doivent
contrôler la formation qu'est la
discipline des jeunes spartiate
il inspecte leur dortoir tous les jours
et leur font passer une inspection
physique tous les dix jours
c'est une tâche plus glamour il leur
faut par exemple vérifier que les jeunes
de 20 à 30 ans ne porte pas la moustache
qui leur est interdite
cette tâche de surveillance inclut aussi
la surveillance des pilotes ont ils
doivent prévenir toute révolte mais
aussi celle des rois
ainsi après le divorce d'eleusis quand
un roi partira en campagne qui sera
systématiquement accompagné d'un effort
les efforts ont aussi un droit de regard
sur la succession royale
par exemple en 540 ils vont forcer le
roi maxandre idas à prendre une deuxième
femme puisque son premier mariage et
stérile sa deuxième femme va tomber
enceinte
mais entre temps sa première femme aussi
et pour départager les deux potentiels
aux héritiers les efforts vont décider
ni plus ni moins que d'assister à
l'accouchement de la deuxième femme
le premier né sera clos men crise de
cette deuxième femme et il sera donc roi
c'est que au maine et le fils
d'alexandre ideas et de sa seconde femme
le célébre leonidas lui est le fils
d'alexandre audace et de sa première
femme étant l'aîné que men sera roi il
fera de nombreuses erreurs il sera
notamment à l'origine du divorce d'eva
this novero à il sera destitué et finira
sa vie en prison
leonidas accédera alors à la royauté
mais l'histoire ne s'arrête pas là
leonidas épousera gorgo la fille de
clymène et donc sa propre nièce
extraordinaire moeurs et royal qui
aujourd'hui encore nous fascine
pardon désolé je sais pas ce qui s'est
passé j'ai vu des têtes couronnées et
j'ai perdu connaissance
bref reprenons la deuxième institution
politique de sparte c'est la geronzi
elle est présidée par les deux rois est
constituée de 28 géronte pour être
géronte il faut avoir plus de 60 ans
donc être déchargés des obligations
militaires il était élu à vie et
n'avaient pas de comptes à rendre
contrairement aux efforts l'élection se
fait là aussi à l'applaudimètre mais il
est probable que tout le monde ne
pouvait pas se présenter et qu'il y
avait une forme de sélection des
candidats pour accéder à cette fonction
était l'aboutissement d'une vie pour
tous par fiat le rôle des gérontes est à
la fois législatif et judiciaire
il prépare les doigts comme les efforts
mais en plus sont un droit de veto pour
contrer ceux ci et l'assemblée s'il le
souhaite il juge les crimes et les actes
de trahison et peuvent prononcer une
peine de mort est compris contre un roi
ils ont aussi un droit de regard sur la
succession royale leur pouvoir était
important et il arrivait que certains
souverains et sept sur les conseillers
par exemple le roi a saisi l'as offrait
un manteau et un bovin à chaque nouvel
élu
vous vous demandez peut-être d'où vient
cette organisation sociale si
particulière et bien comme souvent chez
les peuples antiques et lacédémoniens
pour remonter l'origine de leur
organisation sociale un personnage
légendaire et à sparte ce personnage
s'appelle li pu larguer les curieux
serait le fils d'un roi de la lignée des
oripeaux ty et vers 700 avant
jésus-christ à travers une constitution
de son cru la grande retra il va poser
les bases du système aristocratique
guerrier il va bannir usage de la manne
et en transfert siat instauré
l'éducation militaire la gauche et est
également inventé et répartir les clés
ross pour imposer ce fonctionnement à
ses concitoyens il va demander à la
pythie de delphes la vie du dieu apollon
sur ce projet de constitution
le dieu à travers la pythie valide la
grande retra qui acquiert ainsi un
caractère sacré la consultation
régulière de la pythie sera d'ailleurs
ensuite une spécificité de sparte la
ville consultant l'oracle de façon
institutionnelle apollon faisant office
de conseiller spécial avant l'heure
après cette validation divine et cures
buffet jury aux spartiates de respecter
la constitution jusqu'à son retour et
pour sceller le fonctionnement dans le
marbre
il se suicide avec un regard un peu plus
historique on peut apporter quelques
explications sur le fonctionnement du
système lacédémoniens d'abord pourquoi
de roi on sait quelle origine ces parts
étaient constituées de trois tribus
ayant chacune un roi on suppose que deux
des rois se sont ligués contre le
troisième ensuite pourquoi une classe
militaire dirigeante et une telle
opposition au président at on pourrait
supposer que la légitimité des
spartiates vient du fait qu'ils sont une
classe protectrice
[Musique]
mais ce serait faire une erreur car il
n'y avait pas que les spartiates qui
allait au combat
il était même probablement minoritaire
dans l'armée lassé des manières puisque
les peyriac aussi combattaient de plus à
partir des années 500 ans avant
jésus-christ les zealotes aussi ont pris
part au combat lors des guerres
défensives et certains textes nous parle
même de 6 ou 7 loto combat pour un seul
spartiate le système aristocratique
guerrier et l'opposition avec les
zealots on peut être dû au fait que ce
parti a connu les invasions d'orienne et
de rien était un peuple issu du nord de
la grèce qui ont migré vers le sud dans
les années 1900 avant jésus-christ et on
suppose que les spartiates sera en fait
issues de ces populations d'orienne
quand les ilotes eux seraient issus des
populations locales réduite en esclavage
sans faire une seule
art on peut aussi se demander quelles
sont les conséquences pratiques d'une
telle organisation sociale tout d'abord
s'il ya une constante dans l'histoire
lacédémone yens c'est la tension entre
les ilotes et les spartiates
cette tension culmine au cinquième
siècle avec des tentatives de révolte en
464 avant jésus-christ un séisme très
puissant ayant détruit sparte et fait
des milliers de morts une partie des
ilotes et certaines cités père y en
profite pour se révolter les
lacédémoniens sont débordés et doit
faire taper là leurs alliés pour
réprimer le soulèvement
finalement et guerre dure dix ans et les
spartiates sont contraints de signer une
paix négociée avec les insurgés
quelques décennies plus tard en 425
avant jésus-christ les spartiates alors
inquiet du nombre pilotes capables de
combattre et craignant un soulèvement
met au point un stratagème très peu
glorieux pour de vérifier les autorités
propose de libérer 2010 lot parmi ceux
ayant défendu la cité lors de la
dernière guerre ceux estimant avoir
mérité cette libération devant se
signaler les efforts organisé
franchissement de ces 2000 courageux
défenseurs servile vous faire une fête
pour célébrer l'événement puis quelques
temps plus tard les font massacrer une
autre constante et l'impact de la
religion sur la politique lacédémoniens
la consultation des dieux il ya des
oracles ou des sacrifices est très
fréquente pour prendre des décisions et
cela a pu conduire d aberration selon
nos critères actuels ainsi en 479 avant
jésus-christ à la bataille de prêter les
signes divins indique que ce l'attitude
défensive donnerait la victoire alors
les spartiates n'attaque femmes en 418
la cité-état envoie deux expéditions et
des la cité d'argos mais à chaque fois
les sacrifices à la frontière sont
négatifs et sparte renonce à intervenir
en 389 l'armée la cdm aniane se fait
surprendre alors que le roi a saisi là
c'est encore en train de sacrifier et
laisse les demies chargée tant que
rituel n'est pas fini le grand respect
des fêtes religieuses a aussi causé
quelques déconvenues
ainsi la participation à la fête des
carnets ya a conduit les spartiates à
arriver en retard à deux batailles
cruciales rester dans l'histoire
marathon et au roi nous allons être en
retard les thermopyles ou leonidas est
arrivé à la bourre et il ne s'agit là
que de quelques exemples pris parmi tant
d'autres cette religiosité des
spartiates aussi été utilisé par
certains droits pour imposer leurs vues
par exemple en soudoyant la pythie afin
d'obtenir des interventions divines
allant dans le sens souhaité également
il faut dire quelques mots sur un
élément spécifique à ce parc qui a
contribué à forger son image de cité
impitoyable la sélection des nouveaux
nés il est vrai que les spartiates
faisait examiner leurs nourrissons par
un jury qui décide et si l'enfant
pourrait vivre ou non cette pratique
peut paraître barbare mais il faut se
rappeler qu'à l'époque dans nombre
d'autres sociétés
le père de famille avait droit de vie ou
de mort sur sa progéniture à sparte ce
qui se passe c'est ce droit a été
transférée à la collectivité et la seat
l'état n'est donc pas un exemple de
cruauté particulière comme on pourrait
croire mais tout cela est anecdotique
par rapport aux problèmes majeurs que
rencontrera ses parts au cours de son
histoire et qui finira par mettre à mal
son fonctionnement à savoir la baisse
continue du nombre de citoyens soldats
ils sont autour de 9000 à la fondation
du système militaire et sont encore huit
mille en 479 avant jésus-christ mais
sont seulement trois mille cinquante ans
plus tard la chute continue ensuite ils
sont 1200 en 371 avant jésus-christ et
seulement 700 en 243 et encore ce
chiffre est trompeur
il n'est alors plus en fait que sans
vraisemblable qu'ils se sont créés une
clientèle en payant les par repas
collectifs pour les 600 autres qui soit
non plus les routes puisque cette époque
on peut le vendre
soit l'on hypothéqué cette baisse
s'explique par une guerre continue
mais aussi par les catastrophes comme le
tremblement de terre de 464 qui a décimé
les familles spartiates également le
fait de n'accepter parmi les semblables
que les spartiates de lignées pures a dû
jouer dans la baisse des effectifs en
empêchant un renouvellement par
l'extérieur
devant cette dégénérescence du système
certains droits vont tenter d'entamer
des réformes dans les années 2 150 à 200
ans avant jésus-christ vers 250 avant
jésus-christ le roi a jusqu'à doit
proposer une réforme
il propose d'augmenter le nombre de
citoyens soldats en donnant des clés
rossa des non-citoyens est ainsi de
faire passer le nom de spartiates et
4500 à l'assemblée accepte la réforme
milla geronzi appuyé par le second roi
utilise son droit de veto pour le
bloquer agissent fait alors une sorte de
coup d'état est fait destituer son coup
droit pour en mettre un à la place
qu'ils soient d'accord avec lui il
invente aussi une règle pour l'occasion
pour contrer les gérontes une règle qui
dit que si les droits sont d'accord ils
sont plus forts que la girose et ce coup
de force passe mal et finalement après
des manoeuvres des efforts agissez son
coup droit sont destitués
il ne sera pas remplacé par un autre à
génial qu'ils partent à partir de cette
date n'aura plus qu'un seul droit issu
de la lignée des oripeaux et de
plusieurs mois suivant influencé par
agissent tenteront eux aussi de réformer
ce système via des coups d'état à chaque
fois le pouvoir royal en sortira
renforcée mais les réformes civiques
aide échoueront systématiquement tenté
c'est bien entre 200 et 250 avant
jésus-christ les citoyens soldats ne
sont plus rien numériquement l'armee est
en grande majorité constituée de
mercenaires le fonctionnement de sparte
n'a plus rien à voir avec celui qui
était le sien lors de sa grandeur et la
cité état n'est plus que l'ombre d'elle
même lors de la conquête romaine qui ne
veut en fait cacher une société alors
politiquement brandt
et bien voilà cette vidéo sur le
fonctionnement politique de sparte est
terminée j'espère qu'elle vous aura
appris des choses je vous donne rendez
vous dans une prochaine vidéo
d'ici là je vous dis portez vous bien et
à la prochaine
[Musique]